le ch est celle des les moulins à
terrebonne compte une centaine de
résidents deux employés dépêché ici
peine à décrire ce qu'elles ont vécu ces
derniers jours en un mot dit que cette
préposée et cette infirmière ont pris
des photos pour documenter les
conditions dans lesquelles elles
travaillent les lieux quand on est
arrivé était insalubre
les chambres y avait des sels de l'ue
réunis par terre ça a été là pendant ces
jours ci mogi remarquer le cas des
patients étaient très hautes et très
salées malheureusement le les yeux
collés dans grèce russes qui ont coûté
la vie depuis plusieurs jours des
cheveux gris leurs vêtements sont
souillés elles décrivent également en
manque de personnel insuffisant pour
faire manger correctement tout le monde
tu venu pour donner des soins de bouche
à une patiente en soins confort donc à
laver plus blanc bien la vue de discuter
avalé puis je me suis rendu compte cinq
six heures le soir qu' elle avait encore
la nourriture dans la bouche donc on
s'était pas assurée qu'elle avait fini
sa bouche et ou qu'on a qu'on en fait la
personne est venue nettoyer sa bouche
après le repos le moi je suis plus
démoralisée quand je sors de l'eau que
que je suis fier de ce que j'ai accompli
ça se peut qu effectivement qui est
[Musique]
l'entreprise propriétaire de la
résidence se défend les situations
rapportés sont des cas isolés selon le
directeur général tous les gens ne vont
pas nécessairement aubin mais tous les
gens autour des non résidents ont les
soins de base qui sont requis à laval
une bénévole dépêché aussi h et celle
des 5 dorothée est elle aussi choquée
j'ai constaté des choses à mon sens
c'est inconcevable
linda est éducatrice spécialisée dans le
milieu scolaire
elle supplie d'autres personnes de faire
comme elle est d'aller soulager les
employés débordés
c'est d'ici les panneaux servant juste
parce que c'est une personne qui est
sensible de nature mais voir excusé pour
les gens malades
comme ça qu'on fût ce bar de mort et y
en a beaucoup qui toi qui y allons pour
pour longtemps c'est réticents comme
quoi la bataille dans les 6 h et celle
des n'est pas encore gagné moi j'ai
encore de l'énergie parce que je viens
d'arriver et puis je me dis que je vais
faire une différence puis c'est pour ça
en fait qu'on m'ait choisi de dénoncer
on prend justement le temps de le faire
pour eux parce qu'on dit on voudrait pas
que nos grands parents se retrouvent
dans des conditions comme ceux c'est
épouvantable ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada morrell